i mean uh  you have to try it well i mean it's not  gonna work whatever you try it  there's one important tactic is if black  rook actually comes down to the fifth  rank to attack white's queen then white  can actually use his rook and go and  capture the black knight there's some  tricks there but white is gonna win a  piece and  all the tactics work in your favor  it's no coincidence it's because you're  on the attack it's because you have the  better pieces white pieces are  coordinated protecting each other all  pointing in the same direction black's  pieces are just scattered  and here we go bishop for night trade  and  magnus now remember that white pawn i  said it that white a61 it helps the  attack wow after all of that is going to  resign  looks like he's resigning here yeah it  is  over sam shanklin loses to world  champion magnus carlsen so magnus  finishing off the day with a win that is